hey this is pressure Walker
suppose that A B and C are real numbers
and the square of a plus B minus five
plus the square of B plus two c plus
three plus the square of C plus three a
minus 10 is equal to zero
find the integer closest to a cubed plus
b cubed plus C cubed
I think sunkolp for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so let's analyze this equation
recall that if x is a real number then x
squared is greater than or equal to zero
that means the first Square will be
greater than or equal to zero the second
Square will be greater than or equal to
zero and the third Square will be
greater than or equal to zero because a
B and C are real numbers
but we know the entire equation is equal
to zero
if any of these terms were greater than
zero the entire sum would be greater
than zero the only way that the entire
equation is equal to zero is if each of
the squares is equal to zero
but the only way that a square of a real
number is equal to zero is if the number
itself is equal to zero
so each term inside of the square is
equal to zero
so a plus B minus 5 is equal to zero B
plus two c plus three is equal to zero
and C plus three a minus ten is equal to
zero we have three different equations
and we now have a system of equations
for a b and c
we can solve for a b and c from these
three equations
here's one way to do that
let's take the first and second
equations and subtract the second
equation from the first equation
eliminating the B variable
this leaves a minus 2C minus 8 is equal
to 0 which means a is equal to two c
plus eight
from here we could substitute into the
third equation
for a
so we have C plus three multiplied by
the quantity two c plus eight minus 10
is equal to zero which means C plus six
C plus 24 minus 10 is equal to zero
which means seven C is equal to negative
14 which means C is equal to negative
two
we can then substitute that a is equal
to 2C Plus 8 which means that a is equal
to 4.
finally we can take the first equation
that a plus B minus 5 is equal to zero
we can solve that b is equal to 5 minus
a which means that b is equal to one
so we've solved for a b and c
but there's one more step
we need to evaluate a cubed plus b cubed
plus C cubed we substitute in and
carefully simplify to get that the sum
of the three cubes is equal to 57 and
that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]